our new role in order to remain
consistent the next Republican State of
the Union response must be delivered by
an actual deer-in-headlights
piston gyro Muhammadu sloppy the
Guantanamo Bay prisoner who's published
diary of torture claims the two female
guards once came into his cell and said
today we're gonna teach you about great
American sex and then forced him to take
part in a three-way has to admit that
part wasn't so bad you know new rule
before Instagram bans another foreign
account for showing a models pubic hair
as they did this week they have to
explain to us out here in LA what's
pubic hair
new rule if you actually want to buy the
vag ankle the new sex toy made to look
like a disembodied foot with a vagina on
top you must first register as a sex
offender I know it sounds harsh but this
is no time for footing that's
horrific things of a guy you roll the
crimp the country of Nepal and the
Himalayas has to learn how a real
democracy operates come on hey Paul
you're better than this when something
is said in a joint session that you
don't like you don't start throwing the
furniture around like an angry teenager
you pout and sulk like a little